Hello, everyone, and welcome
to the 20th anniversary
celebration,
extravaganza, party,
celebrating 20 years of
Hedwig and the Angry Inch.
My name is Peppermint and I know
if you are anything like me,
then you know exactly
where you were
the first time you ever heard
of Hedwig and the Angry Inch.
I was working as a make-up
artist at the make-up counter
during the day for MAC Cosmetics
when "Angry Inch" the lipstick
came out to celebrate the film.
And at night, I was
working at Don Hill's
in drag as a superstar--
a future superstar.
And I had no idea that
20 years later I'd
be here sitting with
the creators, the stars,
and the luminaries
of this very, very
transformative story, piece
of art, this cult classic.
I was just beginning my
gender journey myself,
and I have so many
people to thank,
and they are all pretty
much in this panel.
So I'm going to jump right in.
He is a Tony award winning
American writer, director,
performer, songwriter,
singer, genius.
He directed and
starred and wrote,
with Stephen Trask,
the musical Hedwig
and the Angry Inch and its
subsequent film adaptation.
Please welcome my friend, John
Cameron Mitchell. (SINGING)
Welcome, John!
(SINGING) Thank you!
OK.
And hold up.
We have a Grammy Award-nominated
composer, musician,
and lyricist who
composed all the music
and lyrics for the
musical and the film.
Please welcome Stephen Trask.
Thank you.
It's nice to be here.
John and Stephen, take us
back to the very beginning.
How did Hedwig even come about?
The short thing is we met on an
airplane from LA to New York,
I believe.
Weirdly, we both had
connections with New Line Cinema
who eventually made the film.
Stephen was reading
scripts for New Line.
He had some family
members who worked there.
I had just done a
film called Book
of Love directed by the
head of New Line, Bob Shaye.
And we just started talking.
When Harry Met Sally was
on the screen, and we both
were the only two
people not watching it.
He had a Fassbender
biography, which
was on the seat between us,
which was an ice breaker.
He's not usually
breaking any ice.
He's making ice.
It was three years later when
we kept bumping into each other.
And I had an idea
for a rock musical,
and we saw each other's work.
I saw his band Cheater at CBGB's
and he saw me in Hello Again
at Lincoln Center.
Peanut butter, chocolate, we
got to do something together.
So the Hedwig character
wasn't really there.
I think in the
back of John's mind
he probably wanted to
base a character on Helga,
his babysitter.
But when we started working,
this character wasn't there.
But I was basically
doing a Hedwig style
show with a rock band and
drag queens at Squeeze Box
every Friday night.
And I was the music director.
I knew "The Origin
Of Love" was going
to be the central
metaphor of the story.
That was the first song.
It comes from Plato.
It is this story of
us being cut in half
and seeking our other halves.
I gave Stephen the
text from Plato
and he came back
with that song whole.
Nothing changed
from that moment.
It was just like the
perfect first song.
That's basically what we had.
And then, so John started
telling me about Helga.
And I said, well, why
don't we make Helga
into a drag character
but she used
to be a singer who used to
perform with our rock star who
was the lead character.
And John was like, I don't--
you were a little
reluctant to do it,
and there was a little
resistance to John doing it,
but we just kind of
poured everything
into that first show,
which was really a riot.
I mean it was just--
We really took our
time in creating
a 30 minute mini-musical.
SqueezeBox was a magical place.
And, Peppermint,
we actually met--
At Don Hill's!
Yeah.
--at Don Hill's, which was the
club where SqueezeBox happened.
And it was a
legendary rock club.
And Michael Schmidt, who was
the friend of Arianne Phillips,
had this club.
He just wanted a place
he could hang out.
We're all like,
let's get a place
where some rock and
roll, drags, mostly
queer but everyone's welcome.
No bad behavior.
This is a new thing
for the early 90s.
It was Stephen
and my dream club.
It was a dream club for--
I wouldn't say a lot of people,
because a lot of gay men
went to clubs.
But it was for all the gay
men who didn't like all the--
Jealousy.
Exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
And this was the place
that we wanted to be.
And there was 1,000 of us every
Friday night in this club,
and it just became--
It was so exciting.
It was like a home.
And we met friends that
are friends forever.
And amazing drag performers
who hadn't used their voices.
They were used to lip syncing.
Suddenly, they found
that they didn't
have to sing like Patti
LaBelle when they're
singing rock and roll and punk.
And they already were punk
and didn't even know it.
So you would get Mistress
Formika, Sherry Vine,
Lady Bunny who suddenly
she's singing Kate Bush
and people are screaming
like no one ever did for her.
But we were both learning
from these incredible innate
performances.
Even Pat Briggs, who did this
character called Torment.
And Jimmy James, who is used
to doing Marilyn Monroe.
But now it's Marilyn Monroe
singing "Stairway to Heaven."
Led Zeppelin.
Yeah.
It was unbelievable.
And it was a ferment.
And I was learning.
I was learning from the great
Jayne County, Justin Vivian
Bond.
These are legends of
drag and trans rock.
That filled us up.
Taught us.
And I was just a
little baby drag queen.
I had to learn four or five
different songs every week.
It could be everything
from the Buzzcocks
to someone would want to do
a punk version of a Barbra
Streisand song.
Or a Depeche Mode song.
It was just every week it
was a new challenge musically
and it was a lot of growth
for me as a musician.
It's funny.
After our first gig, the
scouts for Woodstock '94,
the reboot of
Woodstock was there.
And they were like,
you're amazing!
We want you to
perform at Woodstock.
And I was like, what?
I couldn't hear.
I was like Wigstock?
Great.
I love Wigstock.
No, Woodstock?
And I don't know what happened,
but I think SqueezeBox --
the other queens were mad at me.
Because I wasn't a
real drag queen and I
get the invitation to Woodstock.
I wanted a group of
people from SqueezeBox,
but they couldn't find dressing
rooms or helicopters demanded
by Mistress Formika.
So that never happened.
But it was the beginning.
It was the birth, and we
kept doing gigs in clubs.
We wanted to keep it
out of the theater
because the theater tended
to tone everything down,
rock and roll wise.
So we developed
eventually for the theater
over four years at
Westbeth, at the Palladium,
at Fire Island, porch parties
where everyone walked away.
We lived Hedwig's life.
But then we finally--
with the great help of Peter
Askin our amazing director,
our first director
and producer--
we eventually landed in
the Jane Street Theater
which he built for Hedwig
because every theater in town
rejected us.
Public Theater, New York Theatre
Workshop, nobody wanted us.
We were too weird.
We were too drag.
We were too punk.
I was a fake drag queen,
a fake rock singer,
and a fake stand-up
comedian, but it was still
too much for them.
So we had to build a
theater for us to--
And it was so custom-made that
at the height of the stage
was set to the height
of John in heels,
and then people went
and sat out where
the audience would
sit and said, let's
make the stage a little higher.
It was that custom.
Yeah, we built it
for Hedwig's wig.
By that point, we had brought in
Miriam's Shor who just blew us
away in an unexpected audition
as Yitzhak, Hedwig's lover
and backup singer.
And I had met Mike
Potter at Kim's Video.
He was one of the
famously surly clerks
at Kim's Video who's like,
"I can't rent you this.
You haven't watched it yet?
This is a classic.
Fuck you, get out."
That whole thing.
And I said, I'm
going to SqueezeBox.
Box.
He's like, "Oh, I go there.
I do wigs sometimes."
I said, I need a wig done,
and he did my second wig
at the show at
SqueezeBox, which was--
Mike, what was it made out of?
Toilet paper rolls with hair
wrapped around it, staples
and hot glue.
And it fell apart on stage.
Like, the toilet --
Perfectly.
--paper was dangling.
I was like I'm fired.
And then he was like,
"Can we do that again?
Can that happen every time?"
I was like, "No!
That can't happen ever again."
I mean, I was like
ready to walk out
and be like "good luck
with your character."
Because I knew I was
fired, but I wasn't.
You've invoked Mike.
So, Mike, hello!
Hi.
Mike Potter is a hair and
make-up artist extraordinaire
who works in editorial,
advertising, celebrity,
and motion picture make-up,
and he's also a painter.
Collaborating with
John Cameron Mitchell,
Potter created
Hedwig's iconic wigs
and make-up for the
musical and film adaptation
of Hedwig and the Angry Inch.
So Mike, we've invoked you.
And we stopped at
the toilet paper roll
wig wrapped in a hair
that fell apart hopefully
at the right moment.
I mean, it must've
been the right moment
if it was requested again.
It kind of didn't fall apart.
Well it started bad
before that, because when
we were standing at
the bathroom door
before he was going on stage
in said toilet paper wig,
he had a cup of
tea in his hand--
Coffee.
--and someone opened
the door and the tea
flew all over his face.
Hot tea.
It kind of like-- it was
like the first setting spray.
It was setting!
Yeah!
It was the first
setting spray ever made.
Then we move forward.
We were doing Fez
and places like that.
And John wanted to
go more structural.
So I was making,
if you can imagine,
you know the tubes
that a dryer has?
Those plastic, metal, the
big tube that's the exhaust?
Oh yeah, the metal ones.
Yeah.
Uh-huh?
I have a picture of John--
because he decided he wanted
to do a side part version--
where that wig is
made out of those,
hair wrapped around that.
And I just remember he snatched
his and the wig flew off.
It was just a series of
unfortunate disasters
and events that kind of
worked for the character
over the years.
But, John and Stephen always
had these beautiful songs.
And the singing and everything
else kind of made up for it.
And it became OK, the tragedy
of the hair and make-up.
To fail.
Yeah I mean, I've always
said the only reason is
Hedwig's hair and makeup is
supposed to be kind of bad
is the way that I was successful
in the end of that process.
You failed beautifully.
You, RuPaul gets it right in
terms of all the skills needed
to do drag.
Meaning, making your own
stuff, you're a designer,
you're an editor, you're
a director, a performer,
sometimes a songwriter.
Drag and to a lesser
extent stand-up,
is the most fully formed
kind of performance
in that you have to do it all.
And oftentimes you're
mixing your own damn song,
putting your own track on.
Oh yeah.
Right?
I learned about--
Hitting play on the player,
running to open the curtain,
and then hurry up and get back
into position for the audience.
Yes.
And they're all like,
it's so glamorous!
You're like, mm-hmm.
That gets to a thing that
we just sort of adapted.
Hedwig always was
wherever Hedwig was.
And so then if
something happened,
it wasn't John and
Stephen's performance
where stuff was going bad, it
was Hedwig and the Angry Inch's
performance--
Exactly.
--where stuff was going wrong.
And that was the reality.
And as long as you accepted
that, it didn't matter.
We're at the Jane
Street Theater.
There would be leaks in
the bathroom upstairs,
and they'd have
to bring buckets.
Dead bodies.
Yes!
Yeah, dead bodies.
And pieces of the set would
come crashing down on us.
You know, hit the bass player,
and he's like bleeding.
We were in a SRO
hotel which means--
not standing room only--
but single room occupancy,
which is like welfare hotel.
And it was like German
backpackers and junkies
upstairs.
And once the audience
was coming in
and they were taking a body out.
And that was our gig.
We were outside
the theater system.
I was such a theater
queen, and Stephen
was such a rock and roll queen.
So we created a third space that
was part theater, part cabaret,
part rock to keep
the character honest.
And then by the time
we got to Off-Broadway,
we opened and nobody
was interested.
The critics really liked us,
but audiences were horrified.
Often very silent shows
like in the movie.
It was only the press
kind of making it hip.
It took Glenn Close
coming 20 times.
And the press agents making sure
that the press was always there
when a celebrity showed up.
And then they would
pack the house
with people with free seats.
They're like this huge
hit downtown that sold out
and all these
celebrities are coming.
It's like, then the
celebrities would go away
and the press would leave and
we performed for like 20 people.
It was totally fake.
But then it would be
like Marilyn Manson
and Barry Manilow
were there one night.
Elliott Smith and Madonna.
Patti LuPone.
You know, it was just
like this mix was crazy.
Pee Wee Herman, David Bowie,
and Bea Arthur and Lou Reed--
And Laurie Anderson.
Pete Burns.
It was out of control.
We were overwhelmed
that our heroes
were here and approving of us.
That drag legends, too,
were approving of it.
Because I still
felt like a fake.
I hadn't paid my dues
as a drag person.
So even though we were limping
along and never really a hit,
we stuck it in there
and suddenly there
was a bidding war for the film.
OK, that is perfect timing.
You've already
invoked her, but I
need to introduce her properly.
She is an actor and
activist who starred in
film, theater, and television.
And, of course, she
starred as Yitzhak
in the Off-Broadway musical
Hedwig And The Angry Inch,
and then later reprised
the role in the film.
Please help me
welcome Miriam Shor.
Hey, Miriam!
I am excited to be here.
It's so nice to meet
you, Peppermint.
I'm just a huge fan.
I know.
You're one of the people
that I haven't actually met.
In person.
I'm over here kind of like
sweating and fangirling.
It's so great to be here.
It's so fun to think
back to all that time.
I was just remembering--
I can remember so vividly
meeting Stephen and John.
It was the first
audition in New York City
that a person ever sent me on.
Was for the workshop.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
What do you mean, that a
person ever sent you on?
I met with an agent.
I was just a kid, and
And they were like,
well, we don't know.
Maybe.
We'll send you out
on a few things.
We'll see how you do.
And the first thing
they sent me on
was to audition for a
workshop version of Hedwig.
It wasn't even fully a play yet.
So I was like, "Oh!
This is amazing.
I mean, this is so--
what is this?"
And I have a piece of paper that
I wrote all the notes down on.
They were like, I wrote
Hedgewick and the Angry Itch.
And they were like, Yitzhak
is a man played by a woman.
Former drag queen
named "Krystal Nacht."
And they were like, you
need to bring a song in.
What did you sing?
Well here's the thing.
And this is kind of magical.
So when we did the workshop,
the last song in the show
was not "Midnight Radio" yet.
It was John as Hedwig
singing "You Light Up
My Life" in German.
And I have no idea why,
I was not asked to,
but to my audition-- and I had
never sung this song before.
I don't know why.
I sang "You Light Up My Life."
Lies.
Lies!
I swear to God.
For real?
I'm not lying.
I don't know why.
Why on Earth would
you pick that song?
I don't know!
Wait, John.
Were you at the audition, John?
Yeah.
It must have stuck in my
brain because later that was
sort of our temporary finale.
I feel like when I met
John and Stephen and Peter,
I just sort of was like, I kind
of feel like I met my people.
And I kind of
understand this person,
even though he's not
really a person yet.
You were so good at kind
of explaining his pain.
But somehow, I just tapped
into that rage and that sadness
that is Yitzhak.
And it just felt
weirdly familiar.
And I just was excited
to go on that trip.
We had no idea at that point.
We weren't Off-Broadway yet.
It was still very new.
And you guys were like, we don't
really know if she can sing,
but we kind of like her.
I take credit for that.
Because we each had names
written on our piece of paper.
And we, like, turned them
over, Peter and John and me.
And Miriam was our first choice.
And we're like, I don't
know if she sings,
but she just seems
like one of us.
We like her.
[LAUGHS]
Miriam also taught me a weird
thing that happens with actors.
You can do things if
your character can
that you can't in your life.
And Miriam hadn't really
sung rock and roll,
but the character had
to scream rock and roll.
And suddenly because the
character had to, she could.
And I find the
same thing with me.
I can like catch a ball really
easy if I'm in character,
but in real life
I'm like Oh my God!
You know?
The world of musical
theater has--
I just always felt kind of--
I always felt like I was
trying to fit into that world
because I just felt like I'm
clearly much more of a freak
than is allowed in that world.
And I just felt
right at home when
I met you and John and Stephen.
I just felt like mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Interesting thing with the
flow of gender in the show,
which is throughout,
is originally
that character was
more of a factotum.
Someone helping out with props.
Craig Chester played a
version of that named Georg.
And when we were thinking
of the real show,
Stephen said it would be
great if that character could
be a backup singer
and I would love
to hear high registered voice.
So I was like, let's
have a person born female
with a high voice or
available high notes
playing a man who wants
to dress as a woman.
So in effect, an AFAB actor
playing a man who wants to do
drag.
And it was perfect
for the piece.
Because we want the
audience throughout to be,
not confused, but aware
that the world is fluid.
We are all-- we all have these
energies that sometimes we
call male and female in us
and we can pull them out
when needed.
Others are more natural.
But some are hidden, and if
you don't let them come out
it's like an animal
that dies in the wall.
It can really
stink the place up.
We were always
aware of the flow.
Hedwig was a boy
named Hansel who
was comfortable in his
gender and assigned a gender
by, in effect, the
patriarchy, by his boyfriend,
and by the government, and
is left alone and crushed
after that.
And it's through drag that,
Peppermint reminded me,
is where the
empowerment happens.
Not necessarily through
a trans journey,
because it was more
of a victimization.
But taking what you've got,
using drag, rock 'n roll,
performance, to find yourself,
to create yourself, as Hedwig,
is the journey.
And a lot of people
can relate to that.
I get a lot, especially
transmasculine people, say,
I love the flow
of gender in this
because as a
transmasculine person,
I want to be able
to do female drag.
I don't want to be
limited by anyone.
I want freedom.
And Hedwig's journey to
freedom is a lot of obstacles.
And, hopefully,
there's fewer obstacles
in real life for others,
but the character
allowed a little space
that all kinds of people
with different kinds of
backgrounds and genders
found the space to be within.
And we love that.
I mean, I will say,
too, playing Yitzhak,
it was such a gift to get
to explore what being a man
means to me as a person.
I got to just explore that
every night, and not just that,
but what a man who wants
to be a drag queen.
So I got to really
go on a journey that
was not afforded people.
This was the '90s.
That wasn't-- I mean, it's still
a struggle for a lot of people.
And it felt like such a gift.
The point was just to explore
it and share it with everybody
watching in that moment.
It was kind of
extraordinary for all of us.
And you could feel it.
It was so visceral in
the theater sometimes.
It was just really electric.
And I remember when we
thought that maybe it
was going to be a
movie, too, which
just seemed extraordinary,
because we were
such underdogs for so long.
Like we always joked,
like, oh, yeah,
we're going to be on Broadway
and like 178th Street.
It's never going
to be on Broadway.
Let's not kid ourselves.
When they talked about
this could be a film,
I remember thinking,
how are you going
to translate that
intersection of excitement
and fear and transgression
and acceptance
that the play was able to do.
So that was kind of
an exciting journey.
Like I said, it was my first
freaking audition in New York,
so I was like, oh,
is this how art goes?
Miriam, you mentioned a bit of
the journey from the workshop
to Off-Broadway to the movie.
I'm guessing there was
several challenges.
But one of the big changes
was, of course, with costumes.
And so I'd like to introduce
this next person, who
is one of the most unique and
creative forces in the fashion
and entertainment industries.
A multi-dimensional
artist, visual artist,
who brings her exemplary vision
to film, fashion, theater,
opera, music, and media!
Ah!
I love her so much.
Please help me welcome
Arianne Phillips.
Hey, Arianne!
Thanks, Peppermint.
So happy to be here.
I'd love to hear your
experiences from once you first
got on board.
How did it begin?
It's very bittersweet,
but I came to Hedwig
through our
incredible production
designer, Therese DePrez,
who's not with us anymore.
We had worked on
a film together,
and she recommended me to John.
And I got the script
for the movie.
And I, honestly, didn't
know what I was reading.
I was like I don't know
what the hell this is,
but it's fucking genius.
There was animation and puppets.
And not your typical
camera angle, panning left,
panning right, dolly moves.
There is incredible
character development.
And I didn't hear the music
because I hadn't seen the show.
I had heard about it.
I got the script.
I read it.
I just knew--
I read it a couple of
times because I really
couldn't figure out
which way was up or down.
But I got the emotion
and the heart.
I trusted Therese implicitly.
And then I went to--
I think it was
the Avalon Hotel--
Yep.
I met Mike and John
at the same time.
I was in the pool.
Yeah, Mike, you were in the
pool, the kidney-shaped pool.
Immediately, I can
really echo what
Miriam said that I felt
like these are my people.
Working in this industry,
we are thrown together
with so many different
types of people.
That's the brilliance.
Different backgrounds,
different aesthetics.
And being a theater
nerd as a kid,
I immediately just
felt seen in a way
just by reading the script and
fell in love with John and Mike
at the same time.
And will forever be
grateful to Therese DePrez
for bringing me in, and for
John taking a shot on me.
I went to New York
shortly thereafter
and saw the show on Jane Street.
I think the first show I saw
was with Ally Sheedy, actually.
And I remember John,
you saying, you've
got to see it with
someone else, as well.
So that was how I
came to the film.
And 20 years later,
some of my family,
closest, we've had
the pleasure of going
through this
unprecedented journey.
And Hedwig is always--
how I explain it--
Hedwig is my Rocky
Horror Picture Show.
When I saw Rocky Horror
Picture Show as a kid,
it was so provocative and it
was about a similar message
in terms of don't
dream it, be it.
Finding your true identity and
using the artifice of sparkles
and hair and make-up
to express yourself
and everything in between
and so much heart.
I feel so privileged to
be part of this family.
It's a connection I
have with strangers,
whether they find
me on the internet
or hear about it on set.
It's multi-generational.
It crosses so many
cultures and ages.
There's no boundary.
And my grandmother,
who isn't with us
anymore, I remember
when she saw the film,
she was so blown away by it.
And that's the power
of beautiful story
and compelling music and
brilliant performance.
And just doing this
film has turned out
to be the most representative of
who I am as an artist in terms
of my creativity and
I just really felt
encouraged by everyone,
John and Stephen and Frank's
beautiful work, and
Mike endlessly-- my costumes
are completed by his work
and were inspired by his work.
There's not a beginning and
an end like most projects.
We all are so connected
and the performers.
So that's my monologue.
Okay, this is perfect timing.
It's time for me to bring in
our next genius who grew up
in Baltimore, Maryland--
right near where
I grew up-- and
studied classical piano
into his late teens.
While learning Italian
in Florence, Italy,
he had the opportunity to
work on a TV commercial there
and was immediately
drawn to filmmaking
and now works in features,
TV shows, commercials,
documentaries, industrials,
webisodes, art films,
music videos.
You name it, he has done it.
Of course, I'm talking
about Frankie DeMarco.
Okay, Frankie, please tell
us how you came onboard.
Yeah.
I came through the
Sundance Film Lab,
through Michelle Satter, who
was running a Sundance Summer
Directors' Lab.
Michelle was looking for DPs.
I think she had already
talked with John.
And just based on the
timbre of my voice
and probably the timbre of
John's voice, she thought,
these two would probably
get along pretty well.
So I went and did the Lab.
To Arianne's point, about
there's the standard way
to shoot everything-- when
we were doing the Lab,
I remember we had these sets
that were just so overused.
And I said, why don't
we flip the set around
so we're looking at the
back of the set that
has the exposed wood.
I think reading the script
and seeing how John works.
He's willing to fail and try
again and fail and try again,
and that's always sort
of been my mantra, too --
I'm willing to fail, let's try
it, and John encouraged that.
So we got along very well
at the Lab and time passed.
Then we ended up working
at John's apartment--
John and I lived
nearby at the time.
It would most of the time
be John and Therese DePrez,
the production
designer, and myself,
and we went through the
script page by page by page
and picked the script apart
and talked about things.
Threw ideas out.
John cherry picked the best
ideas and made changes.
John, how did the movie
come about and tell me
about the challenges of
being a first-time director.
Well, it was a strange
situation, like I mentioned.
Stephen Trask had connections
with New Line Cinema,
so did I. Bob Shaye who
ran New Line was really
my godfather with this.
And Bob directed me in
the movie Book of Love.
And in my audition--
I hadn't read the script
till I got in the office--
and he said, what do you think?
And I said my
character is really
written very homophobically,
Bob, I have to be honest.
This was like in '88 and people
didn't really say those things.
And he's like, well,
it's homoerotic.
I'm like, well, homogeneous
begins with homo, as well.
They all mean different things.
So the characters are very--
every negative stereotype.
And he said, oh, I
didn't think of that.
So how would you do it
if it was rewritten?
And he eventually rewrote it.
But years later,
he came to the show
on the behest of Mike
De Luca, and there
were tears in his eyes after.
And he said, you were
very straight with me
in a creative, engaging
way with Book of Love
and I appreciated that.
And I'd like to help you--
I'd like to finance this film.
And they were supportive of
me directing it and starring
in it, which
wouldn't happen now.
It would have to
be some big star.
And suddenly we
were the hot thing.
So everyone would show up.
Danny DeVito really
wanted to produce it.
Forest Whitaker
wanted to direct.
I said to Forest, I actually
would like to direct.
He said, John, that would
be a terrible mistake.
And I was like, Forest,
I hardly know you.
Is that what you said?
Forest--
That's what she said.
I mean, I hadn't
directed before.
So it was a bit of a risk.
I directed it on stage, so it
was a strange moment when--
independent film,
it's not hip anymore.
It's not part of the zeitgeist.
It was in the '90s.
In the 2000s there was
numbers of companies
who were financing, and
we had a bidding war
amongst a number of companies,
even though we were not
a big hit financially,
we were a critical hit.
And we had an opportunity.
So we knew we really wanted
to work with New Line
and eventually we brought in
Killer Films, Christine Vachon,
who's my hero, who worked
with Todd Haynes and all
of these great people.
We also had a good
year to work on it.
So I went to the Lab, met Frank.
I remember the first time
I directed a scene on film
it didn't go that well.
The second one, Michelle said
to me, you're a filmmaker now.
And I started crying.
And it was a
beautiful experience.
And I trusted Frank.
Even though he didn't
have the credits
necessarily that
New Line wanted,
I had a great vibe with him.
And I said no to all
these more famous DPs.
And that was the right
decision because Frank DeMarco
and Andrew Marcus, the
editor, in many ways
were co-directors for me.
They were much more experienced.
Andrew had worked
with Merchant Ivory,
Room with a View, Howard's
End, Remains of the Day.
And Frank was this gutsy,
scrappy, New York-based guy
coming up from the pit.
And it was a perfect mix.
And Stephen had these
connections with New Line, too.
So there was a kind of family
vibe with New Line where
we felt safe.
Do you think that made you feel
more safe to direct yourself?
Because I think that sounds
like the ultimate nightmare.
That was very scary.
In some ways doing
the show I was
kind of directing
myself then, too,
and never being able to see
it because I was on stage.
So I was used to kind of
directing, but it was--
and I knew what I loved.
I knew I loved Altman and
Cassavetes and Bob Fosse.
And All That Jazz in some
ways was the most influential
on this.
The idea that each scene--
The movie?
Yeah.
The fact that each scene
could have a different style.
And if there was
a strong narrator
you could hold those
different styles together.
So it was films like
that and Nashville
that I was thinking
about for this.
A lot of '70s stuff.
And I like the fact
that even kids today
can't tell when this was made.
They're like, '70s?
'80s?
It's out of time, which I like.
And Frank and I made
sure we shot it on film,
and that was a big deal.
So we had an unusual
situation where
we had financing, distribution,
before we even shot.
And we had a good year
to develop it and go
through every scene,
Frank and I. There
would be no way we could shoot
it if we didn't have that year.
I didn't have enough experience.
We bit off way more
than we could chew.
I'm off over there
putting a wig on
while Frank is
shooting the grip's ass
as a substitute ass for myself.
And Andrew, the editor,
is shooting gummy bears
in close-up.
And I'm like, it's
just like SqueezeBox!
We're just barely
getting it together.
We organized what was
called the insurgency.
Arianne, Mike, and Frank
stole costumes and make-up.
Frank stole film stock
and had his own camera,
and we shot some scenes
in my apartment in Toronto
on a weekend illegally.
And shot stuff without
sound with Mike Pitt and me
that ended up in the film.
And we would never
have got those things
if we hadn't broken
all the rules.
Even the crew was overwhelmed
with our rock 'n roll style.
I remember the AD was just--
he would just, he started
crying and we ended up
having to assistant
direct it, too.
I was like, move those trucks!
We had Drag Day and
all those Canadians,
they wouldn't even take my help.
Ari, you and I were like
the least drag out of all.
The AD showed up in like tutus.
You had these people who I think
until this film would never--
it would not have occurred
to them to think about drag.
Teamsters and drag.
And it was a day where
everyone was in drag
and that's how we shot that day.
That would be my ultimate fan--
that's how I see the world.
Everyone is in drag.
Put your frame of mind there
to be a drag performer.
Even in the smallest way.
Like, it just opens
something for you.
And everyone on set is
doing that, it's just
going to open something up.
And it was such a scrappy
sense on that film,
very much like what
you were talking about,
Stephen and John,
when you were talking
about being Off-Broadway.
The way that Hedwig
was Off-Broadway
was not like we had to fake it.
It was whatever happened
was what happened.
And being on that stage was
reacting to whatever happened.
I've never felt more alive in
the moment of a theater piece.
And that was very much
translated to the screen.
I was going to say we
lost one of the locations
and then we just had to
shoot that tire scene.
Remember that?
And it was like, that's right.
That feels right for
Hedwig, that you're scrappy
and that you have to make
do with what you have
and that it actually
is beautiful.
The beauty of the
piece, too, is that it
evolves around kind of
the circumstance you're
in that day when you're
performing or shooting.
It lives on.
Hedwig has her own
energy, and that's
why it's authentic at any time.
Well, Hedwig also only had two
costumes in the original stage
production.
But in the film she had 41.
So can you talk about that?
And how you would
go from two to 41?
Well, the first thing I said to
Ari, whose earlier work blew me
away--
I said, Ari, Hedwig's
costumes have
to be creative,
unique, and affordable.
Because she is working
out of thrift shops.
And Ari is like, done.
She brought in stuff
from earlier movies
she'd worked on or abandoned
or rock 'n roll music stylist
stuff.
I was wearing Britney
Spears' skirt.
I was wearing
Cameron Diaz's shirt.
It was like she was a
hermit crab and a scavenger.
Right, Ari?
Well.
Yeah.
I mean, what I would say
it's like method costuming.
Getting into the character
doesn't stop with the actors.
It's really like-- I
always say that costumes
are a beam-me-up suit for
an actor to access a time
and place in the character.
And I take that seriously.
Unfortunately for John--
It was torturous.
It was torture.
Mike Potter and I cutting the
hair dress and Mike and John
crying, literally, on a
Saturday in our hotel because--
I shaved his eyebrows off.
Yeah.
Which still haven't recovered!
Except RevitaBrow,
Peppermint, that we all love.
Ari, remember we went to the
Valley and we went to the
By The Pound stores,
and you got some really
great-- like that mall costume.
Like the Rickie Lee Jones,
like pink with the beret.
It was like Ari had all
these great resources that
was high and low.
Goodwill.
Badwill.
High, low.
But, like, a lot of low.
But Ari can always make
it beautiful somehow.
John, you tasked me with that.
And that was just the
kind of meaning that I
could put into those costumes.
And it was doable
and really like fun
and ripping them apart and
putting together as Hedwig
would.
And, actually, I think that
has informed me in my work
ever since.
To try and approach
the costumes as if--
how a character
dresses themselves.
And Hedwig was just the riches
and gifts that kept on giving.
Mike, can you tell us about her
hair and her look in the movie?
30 wigs.
That sounds like a fantasy and a
nightmare all at the same time.
So I went in, and the
studio was, like, well
we're going to have you
oversee, and you're not
going to do John.
Like, we have other people--
union people.
And I'm like, I'm the only
person that's touching John.
I didn't have an assistant.
I had to do some of
those wigs in triplicate.
John never wanted
to wear a bobby pin,
so they would fly off his head
and it would be like, cut.
The wig flew off.
But I just remember a lot
of Arianne teaching me.
It was my first movie
I ever did was Hedwig.
I think Arianne was really
a guiding force for me.
And John let us,
at a certain point,
kind of do what we wanted.
And I did.
I came from that all drag Don
Hill's world where you threw
together a bunch of things.
And luckily Ari had things
a little more planned out.
But I just remember we
had planned out wigs.
Well, we had looks planned out
and then at the last minute
they would just change.
Or Ari would be like,
this is all I got--
these glitter shoes.
And I'm like, okay, I'm going
to do a lip to match the shoes.
Not that you would
ever see them together.
But we tried to
connect and I think
having the freedom to be allowed
to do what we wanted to do.
And I come from kind of
sort of like a little bit
of a trashy background.
He comes from like Sharpie
in your dark roots.
That's you.
Oh.
Yeah.
I give all my cred to Arianne.
I mean I always tell people
she taught me everything
I know about working on a film.
Can we talk a little bit about
the production designer Therese
DePrez?
Therese, in some ways, was--
I mean Ari, too-- but
Therese in some ways
had worked longer in
film than any of us.
And I knew her from
the Killer Films days.
She did a film called Dotty
Gets Spanked with Todd Haynes.
She was the hip,
New York person.
She was seven feet tall.
She had the best
taste in the world.
Her apartment was just full
of shit that was beautiful.
Her wedding was the most
designed wedding of all time.
I sang "Origin of Love."
And she was pure.
She was pure New York cool.
Hip without the attitude.
Just sweetie.
She came in and brought
in Ari because they
had been working together.
I brought in Mike and Frank --
and Andrew was new to all of us.
And Stephen, of course, is
bringing in his musical people
from different angles, too.
So a lot of people who
didn't have film experience.
But we had grand old Therese,
who did a very difficult shoot.
I'm not sure how-- it was like,
really hard on her physically.
She never slept.
Magician.
Every detail.
Bilgewater's restaurant,
the worst seafood restaurant
in the world with decorations
of sinking ships on the wall.
It was a sinking
ship-themed TGI Friday's.
Detail.
Layers and layers
of story and detail.
Like the oven in the
German apartment and--
Oh my God, there was so much.
It was more than
we could afford.
Not afford.
More than we were worth.
We had tons of references.
So we were all in the same
world when it was time to shoot.
Because usually films
people don't work
unless they're on the clock.
And we were all working
for nothing early on.
Usually it's like three
months before, right?
And that's why things look
half-assed these days.
But this looked considered,
thought through, fun, varied.
And I was learning from them
as I only knew what I liked.
I didn't know exactly
how to do anything.
I want to ask the whole
panel about the movie
and how cinematic it was with
the bouncing ball, animations
and just all the things that
were done with the split
screens that you couldn't
do in the stage version.
I'd like just free for all it.
No, I was just going to say.
I mean because we were
shooting a live-action movie,
no longer a stage play on one
single set with no set changes.
And we had to work with
an animator, Emily.
Emily Hubley.
We also had a lot of
visual transitions
because we would go from
live-action to animation back
to live-action.
You have to film in such a
way that this cuts together.
So I think literally, we had
a year of free preparation
meeting at each
other's apartments.
It really helped because the
movie has a ton of transitions,
and I think it's part of the
charm and the fun of the movie.
To go from East
Berlin suddenly bang
we're into the next
place or whatever.
Animation or another new set.
That question I asked before,
which I kept asking myself,
which was like, how are
we going to translate
this visceral energy of
doing live theater way over
on the West Side
Highway when that was
a place people were unsure of.
It wasn't a cool, hip place.
There was a sense of subversion
and danger in that play.
And we are all in it together.
And I was like,
how are you going
to translate that into a movie?
We all going to be on
this ride together.
How are we going to feel like
it's dangerous, yet inclusive,
and subversive yet home.
How is that going
to come together?
And I feel like everyone
put so much of themselves
into it when I watched it,
I was like, oh that's how.
You're going to use
everything you can use in film
and throw out a rule book
that tells you can't do that
in film, and make sure
the glitter looks exactly
right, which Frank would do.
What film will make this
glitter look perfect?
Or this particular undergarment
that no one will ever see,
Arianne is going
to make perfect.
That immediacy translated.
And that alchemy that's in
a stage piece that works
was there in the movie,
and it's so rare.
Because it's almost unnamable.
But, I mean, it has to do
with the heart and the work
and the artistry that gets
obsessively put into it.
And we were away from home.
We were all in Toronto.
We were in a different country.
I don't know how
many days we had,
but we certainly didn't
have enough days.
That energy of getting that
done and not losing a scene.
Stuff like, for me, in post
seeing John as Hedwig flying
over Bilgewater's and Emily's
animation and all those tasty
special vision is what created
that other dimension of magic.
There is a magical
reality in Hedwig
that is grounded in
this soulful heart story
about being true to ourselves.
And the alchemy.
Exactly what you said, Miriam.
Do you guys remember?
Is the Wig in a
Box-Brady Bunch look, was
that one of the
last scenes we shot?
I think it was and it was
like we'd been up all night.
We were laughing during that.
We all got the giggles.
We're so exhausted.
Like heightened reality of
having shot for so long.
And then we're doing this
absolutely fantastically absurd
thing.
You can see it in the shot
if you're watching us there,
we're all barely holding
on and keeping it together.
It's funny because when I
wrote the original script
I didn't think budget.
And Hedwig was performing in
a lot of different places.
Like a airport lounge.
That was going to
be a conveyor belt
camera shot discovering her
in the airport lounge singing.
And then in a rest stop.
And then "Wig in
a Box" was going
to end up in a garbage scow
barge off of Staten Island
with the helicopter shot.
Christine Vachon was
like what if it's
the same restaurant but a
different branch every time?
I'm like, all right.
And then it was
Bilgewater's, which was fun.
And we used the same restaurant
and different angles of it.
So it's-- again, the
hermit crab thing.
You take what you got and
then you'd gussy it up
and that is the spirit of drag.
There was one thing about that.
To me, like, the greatest
moment was the wall
of the trailer coming down.
When John and Therese and I
were in pre-pro we were talking.
It was originally written
as a daylight scene.
And I said, what if it
were a nighttime scene.
Does it matter if
it's day or night?
John's like that would be okay.
This is such a spectacular--
when the music changes and
it opens up and goes crazy.
And they're shimmying
and shagging, can't we,
like, blow off the roof and then
have all four walls fall down
and it becomes this
crazy stage or something?
And Therese-- she has to--
I don't deal with money.
She has to deal with budget.
And she's like, guys,
we can't do that.
Okay, fine.
But then she said, you know
what, I did a movie once
where I had one wall come down.
I can give you one wall.
And then John's like, we'll
put footlights on the wall!
And that just became the
movie and it was brilliant.
That was, to me, one of
the most charming moments.
Then when we actually came
to the day to film it,
I was very worried about
how am I going to film this
as a cinematographer.
And I remember, I was having
panic the night before.
How am I going to do this?
This is set up for failure.
Then I put on the song.
I had like a little
tape deck players
in my hotel room in Toronto.
And I put this song on,
I listen to the song
and I realized no problem.
We're going to do this.
So thank you, Stephen.
An example of the
rock 'n roll, too--
Exactly.
--we're under a power pylon.
The trailer park is under
one of those towers.
And Frank is again in
the spirit of SqueezeBox,
there's like two
electrical grips.
One with the light and one with
a CD that's reflecting that arc
lamp onto the pylons.
That's that crazy
light on there.
It's just a CD.
It's crazy.
That was the money
shot, too, I think.
Totally.
Because that was when you
had the full pull-back.
The crane?
Yeah.
We had the hair dress.
And the animation with
the bouncing ball.
Totally!
Good stuff.
A lot going on.
Only the crazy, sick, twisted
mind of John and Stephen.
And so Stephen, I want
to ask about shooting
the musical numbers.
I'm curious, how much,
if any, did the score
change for the film?
We just rocked harder.
Everything about
it just felt more
aggressive than on the stage.
It was more guitar heavy.
Little more punk.
And what was one of the
things that was really
fun for me besides
rerecording the songs
and getting a different
sound was the actors
all learned to play the
instruments of the people
that they were playing.
Obviously, I was
playing my own parts.
Bob Mould was not in it.
Ted Liscinski, who played
bass on the recording,
played the guitar player,
and so Bob taught him
how to play all the parts.
The guy who played
the bass player,
Ted taught him how to
play all the stuff.
They came to the rehearsals,
and Michael learned
how to play the drum parts.
He knew every drum part.
The way that we did it with all
the musicians actually looking
like they were playing
the instruments.
And then the monitors that
they had next to them that
looked like they were
listening to them
were actually playing their
part out into the house.
And so then we had this audience
of extras who actually believed
they were at a concert.
So we were there
doing it and they
were responding like they
were seeing a band perform.
And none of us were
actually playing.
But it gave that impression.
It felt very magical
every time we did it.
Just really quickly,
can everybody
tell me your favorite
moments or memories
from the shoot and the film?
I would say Therese and I
were next to the camera,
and John was singing
'Origin of Love'
and we both were crying by
the time the song ended,
holding each other,
and it was very sweet.
Yeah.
Mine was every
day at lunch, John
would have to shave
his face in full drag.
And we would never know
was the make-up going
to-- what was going to happen.
We would shoot all the
close-ups at the end,
and it was always,
like, 40 filters.
But I just remember
John every day at lunch.
Full drag.
And directing in the chair,
but he would just shave.
You can shave through
make-up if it's an electric--
Yes.
You can.
I have to say that last shoot.
That last 'Wig in a Box' moment
with us singing the song,
and it was the end of the shoot.
And we sort of knew
that, and was this sort
of really magical moment.
And we're all just insane
by the end of the night
and the end of the shoot.
That, and then also the moment
where Hedwig gives Yitzhak
the wig that we shot.
That was just a really-- it's
always an emotional moment
playing Yitzhak.
But it was so beautiful
the way that it was shot.
The whiteness-- Therese--
I mean just the look
of it in that moment.
And then people catching
me as I fell back,
and then I got to be in drag.
I felt like an alien angel.
It was just this combination.
So it was a really
meta moment where
I felt like Yitzhak
was getting a dream
and I was also getting a
dream to sort of come true
in that moment.
I just remembered.
There is actually
one song, which
is 'Hedwig's Lament'
which was the one time,
it felt like everything
had stripped down
and John and I are
both performing live.
The piano that you hear is
me playing whatever piano
it was that happened--
I don't even know if
we tested that piano.
It was not, like, the most
awesome piano in the world,
but it was perfect
for that song.
In that whole like
production where everything
just kind of blew up into
much larger proportions
and then just before
it blew up there
was this one moment
where it like
zeroed in on just John and
me performing live together,
which somehow feels
really special to me.
I had a lot more fun directing
other people than myself.
I think in the moment during
Tommy's 'Wicked Little
Town' when Tommy is singing
to Hedwig in this black void.
And I was able to let
go, you know, and cry.
There had been so much tension.
I don't think I'd taken
a shit for a month.
I had an anal fissure.
Ouch.
Okay.
I shouldn't have
started laughing.
Hello.
Ouch.
It was such a journey,
harder than anything
I will ever do before or
since or in the future.
Even though I didn't
really want to act in
that because I had
done that, that
was an opportunity
to cry in a good way.
Hedwig is crying
for the boyfriend
finally apologizing
and letting go.
Letting her go.
Him being let go, as well.
And that's the beginning
of forgiveness,
because Hedwig is a victim.
Acts like a victim throughout.
I'm a fucking victim.
And is very mean to
people because of that.
I got hurt, therefore
I'm going to hurt you.
I'm justified in
hurting, which is what
so many people feel right now.
It's like everyone is
a professional victim.
And I admire the
people who create
the professional alternatives.
Yes, we know there
are grievances,
we know there's injustice.
What are you going to do?
Rather than saying you're
hurting me or I hate you,
you're canceled.
It's like how do we create
an environment where when we
find the things in common, where
we allow people to even change?
But I really think
Hedwig's story
has resonated for more people
than we expected, because we've
all felt put upon.
We've all felt like a victim.
And if you stay in that
mode, even if you're
the most powerful
victim, you're still
under the power of the
person who hurt you.
And you've got to
find a way to forgive.
And if they don't take the
forgiveness, then you move on.
John, you said that Hedwig
is not a trans story.
And you talked a
little bit about this.
But can you go in a little
bit on what Hedwig is about
if it's not a trans
story for people
who might describe it as such?
Yeah, I really don't see it as--
I don't think that's the
best way to look at it.
It is a story of this boy
Hansel who is in a lot of cages.
There's the cage
of East Germany.
There's a place that is
not welcoming to his very
creative queer side.
He is in a cage of
masculinity that he feels
there's more space for more--
femininity, whatever
you want to call it.
It's a person who is raped
as a child, which is implied,
raped by his father.
There is abuse throughout.
Ultimately, there
is this operation
that he's kind of forced into
by his boyfriend and mother.
And, in fact, his government.
To be free, you have
to change your gender.
And this is how we
define your gender.
No penis means you're a woman.
What a horrible way
to define femininity
is-- with a negative.
And the inch being
a metaphor for what
is left of that abuse,
what is the scar,
the remnant of these
people having hurt him.
And when he does end up
in a trailer in Kansas,
alone, abandoned by that man
who in effect mutilated him
without much consensual
choice, not allowing him,
as Stephen said, to go on
his own gender journey,
but forcing it, that's
an example of top
down, forcing people
into these narrow places
they didn't expect to be.
We all end up in
these narrow places,
and we've all had
some bruises and,
hopefully, not as
horrible wounds
that Hedwig has experienced.
And then there is the next
step, which, Peppermint,
you identified as self-creation
to me, which is like,
in effect, in drag, which is
a tool that anyone can use.
Straight, cis, queer, trans
can use drag in a special way
to defend yourself with armor,
but also to create a canvas
to express yourself safely.
That is when Hedwig puts on
the make-up, finds that wig,
and makes something
beautiful and new.
Which is more than
a man and a woman.
It is a gender of one.
And so that's why
I don't think--
I mean, it's a trans in
terms of crossing boundaries.
Yes.
But not necessarily the
traditional definition
of transgender, which is I'm
finding myself through agency,
through volition, through
sometimes physical changes,
sometimes just identification.
But the deeper elements
of finding yourself
through the woods,
through the abuse,
is one that trans
friends have told me
they've found use in Hedwig.
Cis friends, queer friends,
gay friends, straight folks.
Outsiders, all.
And to limit the
character being played
by one category or another goes
against its actual message,
which is self-realization and
finding your own wholeness.
In the end, Hedwig doesn't even
need the tool of drag anymore.
And in horror and
frustration, tears it off
and walks into the world naked
with a scar saying take me
as I am or don't take me at all.
I no longer need this defense.
And I see Hedwig now as
probably a non-binary professor
of German philosophy
and rock 'n roll
in a small Midwestern
college about to lose her job
and healthcare.
I will take that
course any time.
I want to ask each of you about
the enduring legacy of Hedwig
and when you became
aware that Hedwig
had become such a cult classic.
I think the first time
I knew it was a cult
hit was when Michael,
who is my husband,
got a job at the University
of Kentucky in 2004.
I started going to clubs.
I met this guy, Duane
Lundy, who owned
a recording studio in town.
And he was working with a
band called Parlour Boys,
and I met him at
one of their shows
and he was recording them.
And he was already
a huge Hedwig fan.
Then I started hanging
out with the band
and I became friends with them,
and everyone in their circle
of friends who are like very
creative and very progressive
millennials, and they
all knew the movie.
They had all watched
it in high school.
Everybody knew it.
They were all big fans.
And then I started going
to clubs to hear bands
and I'd meet people
at the clubs.
And they're always like 24,
and they'd be like Oh my God --
I'm such a huge fan.
We were in Lexington,
Kentucky, and I
was like, I didn't have
any clue that was going
on in the country as a whole.
For me the legacy
personally is that Hedwig
changed the trajectory
of my choices
that I've made in my career
and in my artistic life.
And it re-calibrated who I
went into blindly pursuing.
And so I'm forever
grateful for that.
And on the larger level, it
has fostered a conversation
that I have with strangers about
meaning and purpose and joy
and celebration and pride
in so many different forms
and a connection to strangers.
And then the physical
legacy is that it
was the only film I ever
owned the costumes for, which
was the deal I made with
Christine Vachon and Katie
Roumel, the producers,
because they couldn't pay me
enough money.
I said, oaky, I'm
keeping the costumes.
And I have donated
almost all the costumes
to the AMPAS museum.
So they have a permanent home.
I've donated all my sketches
and will live on and hopefully
that physical
legacy, people will
get to enjoy the costumes
in future exhibitions.
And so I'm super
grateful for that.
I keep meeting people
every day who were affected
by Hedwig here in Brisbane.
I was trying to get
my rent stabilized
apartment form notarised
here in Brisbane.
And the secretary
is like, you know
you have the same name
as an actor on Broadway.
Have you heard of Hedwig
and the Angry Inch?
And I'm like, that's me.
And she's like, no way!
So it filters not
in a massive kind
of shoved down your throat by
marketing Marvel Universe way.
It bubbles up from the bottom.
It's passed on word of mouth.
A person gives it to
a friend, the DVD,
or now it's just streaming.
I've heard of multiple
people saying,
when I start dating someone I
have shown the film to them.
And if they don't like it,
we don't continue dating.
You know, I love being
a dating litmus test.
[LAUGHTER]
And it kind of resonates, again,
throughout sexualities, ages,
genders, race.
There's a sense of understanding
when you've been knocked down
and you're trying to put
yourself back together.
Find your wholeness.
Find that other half, even if
it's an internal other half.
And it's found its way--
the countries that have welcomed
it most, Korea, Japan, Spain,
Australia, France.
These are places we
didn't expect to resonate
with something unusual.
Because Korea and Japan aren't
super queer-relaxed places.
But the story itself,
especially Korea--
I'm actually a
rock star in Korea.
Stephen and I can go there and
perform to 10,000 people in one
night.
And K-pop stars show up and
they're like, we love Hedwig!
Partly, their flag is
the yin yang symbol,
which is similar to
our Hedwig symbol.
That it is a broken nation,
just like Germany was broken.
So the queer stuff aside, we
get so many people resonating
to different parts of the story,
which is so gratifying to us.
And the people I've met
just because of this project
are some of my favorite people.
It keeps giving.
When I meet a
trans kid in Sydney
who's just coming
up and saying you
gave me a little bit of hope
that there was some space
for me to make myself.
Not make myself in the
image of Hedwig or you,
but make my own journey.
That is the most
empowering compliment
any artist can have
is that it made
someone feel that they could do
something they didn't know they
could that has helped them.
I think that it's a piece
of art about identity,
about national identity, right?
It's one of the only
pieces of American art
I know of that deals with
the Berlin Wall falling.
And the Berlin Wall
was this moment
of identity for everyone.
People all over the
world identified
who they were as nations based
on which side of the wall
they were on.
And we sort of forget that
now because it's gone.
It just dissipated
and disappeared,
but it was how people define
themselves as nations.
Binary.
Yeah.
And that same split.
So unnatural to split
something and say pick a side.
You cannot go-- there's a
no man's land in between.
You don't get to go
over it or you'll die.
That kind of feeling of
searching for identity,
it was so beautifully
put into this piece that
was like East, West Germany
but also male, female yin, yang
and who are you in that world?
Where do you exist?
When do you get to
make that decision?
And I feel like Hedwig
asked that question
with music, which is the most
visceral way to ask a question.
And people just responded to it
because it asked that question
of you when you watch it.
And some people maybe it
felt like the first time
they were allowed to answer.
In the last 20 years, John,
since the movie was released,
what would Hedwig think?
Hedwig would be
where's my money?
[LAUGHTER]
I'm playing Joe
Exotic right now,
and there's a lot in
common with Hedwig.
Right?
Sudden fame, jealousy,
anger, young boyfriends.
You know, before the pandemic,
I would have not understood
that, but now I totally get it.
What do you think, Stephen?
What would Hedwig be doing now?
I think she's saying that
there's too many walls, not
enough bridges.
That's right.
You find a point of
connection between you
and another person,
or another group.
And you can make it into
a wall or you can make it
into a bridge, and
Hedwig would prefer
to make it into a bridge.
OK.
So I want to say thank you to
each of you for spending time.
I want to say thank you
to everyone watching
and, of course, I want to say
thank you to the Academy, which
I've always wanted to say.
I have no business, but
I'm going to say it!
Now, John, Stephen, Arianne,
Mike, Miriam, Frankie,
thank you so much.
Congratulations, to each of you.
And to everyone that had
anything to do with this film,
with the Off-Broadway, with the
workshop, with the West End,
with the Broadway
production, any iteration.
And, of course, the
many, many people
who have the fortune to work
on and be associated with any
of the subsequent
productions that
have been on stage, thereafter.
Congratulations to 20
years and thank you so much
on behalf of so many people who
are gender expansive, gender
explorative, and beyond.
Thank you, Peppermint.
We love you!
Peppermint, we love you!
Thank you.
I love you.
Love you.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]